[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous invite un sursaut collectif
un sursaut vital comme on va le voir
depuis une dizaine d'années je fais un
travail de prospective
multidisciplinaire consacré aux
vulnérabilités des sociétés modernes
en gros je caractérise des
problématiques systémiques auxquels
l'humanité est confrontée élabore des
propositions pour traiter ces
problématiques en éliminant les fausses
bonnes idées ce qui ne peut pas marcher
c'est à dire la quasi intégralité de ce
qu'on nous présente comme des solutions
aujourd'hui je partage avec vous mon
analyse et vous allez comprendre
pourquoi il m'arrive de mal dormir la
nuit
l'an prochain quart d'heure je vais
énoncer les principaux défis auxquels
l'humanité est confrontée
j'expliquerai pourquoi les stratégies
dont on dispose pour s'attaquer au
changement climatique aux enjeux
d'énergie de ressources ou de sécurité
alimentaire par exemple pourquoi ces
stratégies sont fondamentalement
inadaptée parce qu'elle passe à côté du
problème principal puis je formulerai
quelques propositions pour inspirer je
l'espère des démarches constructives et
pertinentes en matière de réflexion
comme d'action nous vivons dans des
décors que nous nous sommes construits
et décors urbains pour la plupart qui
occulte la nature mais aussi des décors
sociaux culturels et idéologiques qui
anesthésie notre sentiment
d'appartenance à la nature l'envers de
nos décors est un enfer pour toutes les
formes de vie qui tente de nous survivre
comme je vais le démontrer notre
civilisation est une méga machine
d'annihilation du vivant et soit nous
neutralisons cette machine folle selon
nous autodétruire ont entraîné dans
notre sillage une myriade d'espèce une
autodestruction qui pourrait advenir
plus tôt quand croix étant donné les
vulnérabilités de nos sociétés nos
sociétés sont clivé entre ceux qui ont
compris que le monde a atteint ses
limites physiques et écologique et que
nous devons redéfinir nos comportements
et ceux qui refusent qu'ils rejettent en
général par principe sans avoir vraiment
étudié la question l'idée même de limite
soit carrément il nie les limites du
monde soit ils en reconnaissent
l'existence mais s'imaginent qu'il
n'existe pas de limites à la capacité de
l'homme à résoudre les problèmes
cette fois un conditionnel est un déni
croire qu'on peut trouver des solutions
au sens d'entretenir le système au lieu
d'en changer c'est chercher à faire
durer le non durables il faut bien
comprendre que cette question des
limites et vulnérabilité de nos sociétés
eni une discussion idéologique ni
affaire d'opinion ou d'intuition
personnel en réalité les dynamicien des
systèmes les experts de la résilience
des infrastructures les spécialistes des
cycles biogéochimiques les écologues
nous enseigne que le monde est un
système complexe régie par des
rétroactions des effets de seuil d effet
boule de neige des effets rebonds et
qu'en raison de dynamiques exponentielle
on a un problème de timing les approches
d'il ya une vingtaine d'années ne sont
plus adaptées en réalité il est déjà
trop tard pour un quelconque
développement durable est nu stratégie
de permettra de dégager des perspectives
enviable et viable tant qu'on ne
considérera pas le problème pour ce
qu'il est un vice de notre modèle de
civilisation
je vous invite à visualiser et une
analyse systémique de la situation le
monde naturel se compose de six faire la
première se faire c'est la lithosphère
l'enveloppé rigide de la terre on en
extrait les combustibles fossiles sur
lesquelles repose notre civilisation
industrielle on en extrait les métaux
dont les terres rares le sable de
construction des nutriments vitaux comme
le phosphore etc et toutes ces choses
butent actuellement sur des limites
c'est une question de stock parfois mais
souvent plutôt de flux et ton en mesure
d'assurer les approvisionnements en
pétrole notamment dans nos sociétés ont
perpétuellement besoin pour fonctionner
la deuxième ce faire ces diderot ce
faire l'ensemble des eaux de la planète
océan mer lacs cours d'eau nappes
phréatiques
elle est dans un état de dégradation
avancé pollution plastique et autres
déchets acidification réchauffement
montée des eaux salinisation assèchement
zone morte
tous les voyants sont au rouge la
troisième force et la cryosphère
l'ensemble des glaces de la planète
banquise inlandsis glaciers permafrost
j'ai un scoop sa faune
et le processus s'accélère quatrième ce
faire c'est l'atmosphère nous en
modifiant la composition chimique si
vite que les cycles de l'eau et du
carbone du cycle est essentielle à la
vie sont totalement détraqué le climat
sort de sa zone de stabilité sans
compter les multiples pollutions en gaz
et en particulier cinquième ce faire la
biosphère l'ensemble du vivant
là c'est une catastrophe à glacer le
sang aide en vain de se dérouler
derrière nos jolis décors
si on exclut l'humanité et les animaux
d'élevage 60% des vertébrés ont disparu
en 44 ans des vertébrés 5 les mammifères
terrestres et marins les amphibiens les
poissons les reptiles et les oiseaux
si on n'entend pas le cri que nous
adressent la nature entendons nous bien
les êtres vivants ne disparaissent pas
nous les exterminer par nos modes de vie
c'est pas un procès d'intention justin
fait sixième et dernière ce faire le
monde naturel la paix dos faire les sols
75 % des terres de la planète sont dans
un état critique en raison des pratiques
agricoles intensives de l'urbanisation
ou des activités industrielles notamment
l'extraction minière et dernièrement les
nations unies nous ont informés nous ont
alertés d'un risque majeur de pénurie
alimentaire mondial voilà l'état
constaté du monde naturel
vous voyez pourquoi je dors mal parfois
à côté de ça et là septième ce faire
l'on propose faire l'humanité les
activités humaines et les productions
humaines construction objets déchets
l'entrepôt sphère explose une croissance
exponentielle qui fait que l'empreinte
écologique de l'humanité la pression
qu'on exerce sur la planète surpasse
désormais ce que cette dernière peut
encaisser question nos sociétés
peuvent-elles durée dans toutes les
composantes du monde naturel sont en
effet de remous en atteinte de limites
non une grande descente énergétique et
matériels s'amorce avec des ruptures
d'approvisionnement et des pénuries en
perspective il faut s'y préparer
apprendre à vivre en équilibre avec
cette nature dont nous faisons partie
si on se croit invincible ne se prépare
pas des effondrements vont bientôt se
produire un peu partout des processus
chaotique à l'issue desquelles nous
devrons assurer nos besoins élémentaires
par nous mêmes
pour bien comprendre en profondeur la
nature de nos vulnérabilités j'ajoute à
ce panorama quatre éléments 1 toutes nos
activités jusqu'aux plus vitales sont
tributaires du bon fonctionnement
continu de chaîne logistique à flux
tendu hors de notre contrôle qui
nécessitent des transports dont 96 %
utilisent du pétrole si vous pensez que
notre sécurité alimentaire énergétique
eau sanitaire est garantie par l'état
les collectivités
détrompez vous en cas de rupture
d'approvisionnement de plus de quelques
jours nous sommes livrés à nous mêmes
2 nous dépendons d'infrastructure réseau
transport de communication d'eau de gaz
d'électricité qui tousse nécessite un
apport permanent de matériaux et
d'énergie pour leur bon fonctionnement
et leur maintenance
trois ans la technologie et le monde
mais ce faisant certes on l'a optimiser
mon a surtout complexifié et fragilisé
nous voici vulnérables à des ruptures
d'approvisionnement des pannes des
hackers des cyberterroristes etc et 4 la
crise sur le gâteau nous sommes à la
merci des emballements de marchés
boursiers instable notre monde entier
est inféodé à un système financier court
termiste dont la finalité est à
l'antipode de l'intérêt général
alors on fait quoi on réclame que les
dirigeants agissent peine perdue quand
bien même il le voudrait sincèrement
leurs réponses sont inadaptées et pour
s'en convaincre
jetons un coup d'oeil du côté du climat
la question qui mobilise la communauté
internationale on a un sommet onusien
annuel des milliards investis un marché
du carbone
on a des innovations les cleantech
greentech smart teck des transitions
énergétiques dans six pays et pas la
moindre réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre 00 pourquoi bon déjà
parce qu'on sentait dans des politiques
de croissance économique ce qui
mécaniquement augmente l'empreinte
écologique on ne sait pas découpler par
exemple produit intérieur brut et demi
son blaze effet de serre à l'échelle
mondiale mais surtout et c'est là le
coeur de mon propos même si nous
arrivions à éviter un dérèglement
climatique cataclysmique ans d'écart
bonnan la civilisation
nous n'empêcherons quand même pas un
effondrement global parce que nos
réponses sont inadaptés parce que l'on
traite le dérèglement du climat comme un
problème alors que ce n'en est pas un
c'est un symptôme
modélisons situations en amont on
prélève des ressources
au milieu on les transforme en biens et
en services grâce à de l'énergie en
avant le rejet des déchets et
dépollution
ces derniers sont solides liquides ou
gazeux et parmi les gaz il ya les gaz à
effet de serre les dérèglements
climatiques sont un des effets
secondaires du fait que cette
civilisation est influent irréversible
noms circulent art is able qui convertit
la nature en déchets et donc de
l'énergie même décarbonés au service de
cette civilisation c'est un maintien de
ce flux qui mutilent les conditions de
vie sur terre la transition énergétique
par exemple pour fonctionner ne peut
être déjà qu'une décroissance
énergétique puis surtout elle doit
s'intégrer dans une vaste palette de
stratégies s'attaquant à la cause
primaire de nos problèmes c'est à dire
visant à changer de civilisation
alors je comprends bien qu'il est
difficile de s'imaginer que la plupart
d'une représentation d'avenir
appartiennent au passé
personnellement ça ne favorise pas mon
sommeil mais soit nous ouvrons une
conversation pour décider ensemble de ce
qu'il faut préserver ce qu'il faut faire
évoluer ce qu'il faut arrêter de ce
qu'il faut encore créé nous pouvons
encore à ménager l'avenir prix soit
vivable et digne soit on ne se prépare
pas et ces choix nous serons bientôt
imposer sous le prétexte de la sécurité
dans des contextes sérieusement
liberticide et le moment du choix
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est maintenant
pas demain maintenant c'est le déclic ou
le déclin je repose donc la question on
fait quoi
eh bien on garde espoir mais pas
n'importe lequel pas l'espoir simpliste
qui consiste à présupposer qu ils
résoudront le problème pas l'espoir non
plus de pérenniser cette civilisation
toxiques et mourantes celui d'inventer
d'autres façon d'être au monde
il faut déconstruire les faux espoirs
pour pouvoir construire des espoirs
lucide et comme le verrouillage du
système sont telles qu aucune sortie par
le haut il viendra d'en haut faut
pousser par en dessous c'est à nous de
jouer
c'est comme ça ça tombe sur nous nous
sommes tous responsables de l'avenir
même si on n'est pas coupable du passé
et ce sont nos choix qui vont nous
déterminer nous définir serons-nous
celles et ceux qui se sont levés pour
cette cause qui conditionne toutes les
autres où serons-nous celles et ceux qui
s'en sont lavés les mains
nous n'avons pas le droit nous laisser
aller à la résignation au désespoir au
défaitisme l'avenir sera ce que nous
allons en faire et la bonne nouvelle ça
y est j'y viens c'est qu'il existe mille
façon constructive d'agir deux grands
chantiers s'impose une révolution de la
pensée
un réveil des actes premier chantier des
colonisés et réinvestir nos imaginaires
c'est la sphère numéro 8
la sphère des idées pour commencer
mobilisons nos créativité pour élaborer
des contrées si inspirants apte à
supplanter le récit dominant du sans
limite qui est une escroquerie loufoque
génératrice de rapport de force
oppressif qui nous condamne à des
dissonances cognitives empêchant tout
bien être chacun doit dès maintenant de
comprendre
loin de s'opposer loin d'être rival
luttes sociales et luttes écologiques
peuvent et doivent se renforcer
il est temps de fonder de nouvelles
cultures basée sur d'autres hiérarchie
de valeurs
alors ok ça a l'air un peu abstrait
comme ça mais en réalité presque tous
existe déjà agroécologie agroforesterie
permaculture maraîchage sur sol vivant
circuits courts locavorisme coopératives
d'habitants réappropriation citoyenne
des communs l'air l'eau le sol les
graines monnaies locales systèmes
d'échangés locaux low tech etc
il existe plein de choses qu'on peut
faire pour vivre mieux et durablement
renseignez vous formez vous transformez
vous ces apprentissages et ses remises
en question requiert quelques efforts
mais ils sont profondément libérateur et
puis à partir de maintenant
demandons-nous pour chaque chose qu'on
fait est-ce que ça participe à
revitaliser la nature et les rapports
humains
cette question doit devenir le réflexe
posez-vous ces questions outre ce
premier grand chantier sur les
imaginaires second grand chantier
concerne nos actes c'est la neuvième ce
faire la sphère dû faire deux types
d'actes complémentaires la résistance et
la résilience pour commencer brison ces
décors qui nous hypnotise et entrons en
résistance contre la mégamachine les
petits pas et les petits gestes
quotidiens
c'est bien mais on n'en est plus là
stopper la destruction contrer la
violence inouïe de cette civilisation
est une question de légitime défense
autant qu'une question éthique
mobilisation citoyenne désobéissance
civique
on a besoin de chacune et de chacun
d'actes emblématique que l'activisme
soit votre truc ou pas écouté faut y
aller là c'est une guerre je sais que
mes propos contrastent avec votre décor
pourtant ne sont ni dogmatique ni
excessif
en fait ils sont même assez banal parmi
les experts des sciences naturelles
c'est notre arrière des corps qui est
extrême et à ce stade la réponse
proportionnée aux enjeux c'est de se
mobiliser avec détermination ensemble
stoppons les activités nuisibles les
projets fous les élites quand elles sont
perverties ou cupides les
multinationales banques cabinets
d'avocats l'oubli quand ils oeuvrent au
service d'intérêts privés contre
l'intérêt général
il faut dire stop à ces choses là si
nous ne le faisons pas qui à nous
d'inverser les rapports de force pour
devenir architecte de l'avenir et non
plus simples figurants et si les états
et les décideurs ont un rôle à jouer
dorénavant c'est un rôle de facilitation
d'une grande transition vers la
résilience un bon leader aujourd'hui ce
serait quoi ce serait un visionnaire
mobilisés au service d'un projet
d'avenir qui soit cohérent inspirant
d'intérêt général ses premiers actes
dessine le contour de la résistance
à côté de ça donc gala résilience
montrer qu'on peut vivre différemment et
très bien sans dépendre de chaîne
d'approvisionnement de l'autre bout du
monde ou de systèmes industriels hyper
capitalistique ou de dispositifs
technologiques ultrasophistiqués vivre
et travailler avec la nature sans
chercher à la dominer avec respect créer
de la cohésion durable devenir
collectivement moins fragiles face aux
limites font don de nouvelles sociétés
en parallèle de ce système un sens et
des sociétés qui prendront le relais
demain
les sociétés libérer de la course au
toujours plus sachant s'autolimiter de
façon digne et solidaire construisons
des alternatives inspirante et un
conseil si vous pensez pouvoir devenir
autonome dans votre coin ou créer votre
petite communauté isolée avec un potager
quelques réserves et puis peut-être même
une une culture défensive
ça ne tiendra pas dans la durée je vous
le dis même si vous êtes très riche
inspirez vous plutôt de l'état d'esprit
du mouvement des villes en transition
ça ne suffit pas mais c'est un excellent
début il s'agit pas non plus d'être naïf
quant aux risques d'insécurité mais
d'instaurer des dynamiques constructif
de coopération en réseau
la résilience ne peut être que
collective pas des lots dispersés mais
des archipels connectés complémentaires
et solidaires pour rendre les
territoires résilient c'est à dire apte
à gérer la descente énergétique et
matériels qui s'amorce tout en assurant
aux gens des conditions de vie décentes
qui que vous soyez contribuer à votre
façon
vous avez du temps ou de l'argent donné
100 pour des projets de régénération des
écosystèmes
vous avez des terres invités idées
alternatives qui prépare l'après pétrole
vous êtes élu ouvrez votre territoire à
des projets de transformation socio
environnemental les gens s'organiseront
vous n'avez rien à faire juste leur
simplifier la tâche
vous êtes patron réorienter l'entreprise
avec un business modèle réellement
soutenable employés et employeurs
élaborent ensemble des projets de long
terme vecteur de sens
vous êtes une école former les élèves à
la création de résidences collectives au
lieu de les formater pour un marché du
travail qui d'ici quelques années aura
totalement changer etc et les tas de
choses à faire
un raz-de-marée d'initiative de
résilience doit déferler sur le monde et
ça ne tient qu'à nous devons nous c'est
un projet de civilisation et tout part
de nous ça ne doit pas nous intimider
mais nous motiver car de beaux de grands
moments se profile si nous avons dépassé
les dénis les hypocrisies les décors qui
nous oeuvrons ensemble avec dignité et
détermination de pouvons encore faire
prévaloir les forces de vie contre les
forces de mort avant de conclure
en avertissements relatifs à la
technologie parce qu'on est ici dans un
cadre particulièrement technophiles la
technologie elle nous fascine mais c'est
un outil et une est bénéfique que s'il
nous émanciper ne transforme pas en
junkie et que s'ils participent à une
des complexification du monde au lieu de
rajouter des strates de complexité qui
nous rendent dépendants une nouvelle
nairobi lise la complexité mène à la
perplexité la perspicacité invite à la
simplicité sur une planète dont les
limites sont atteintes la technologie
n'a de sens qu'au service d'un grand
projet de l'humanité pour l'avènement de
nouvelles façons de vivre qu'ils soient
protectrice et non plus exploiteuse de
la nature renouvellement des imaginaires
résistance résilience tout est là c'est
la clé si après avoir entendu tout ça
vous ne savez pas par quoi commencer
voici mon conseil il s'applique à
n'importe qui organiser dès que possible
des conversations dans votre entourage
communauté voisinage résidence
entreprises des réunions physiques si
possible pour discuter ensemble des
limites et des vulnérabilités des
ressources des richesses culturelles qui
sont les vôtres vous y rencontrer des
gens qui partagent vos prises de
conscience et vous trouverez ensemble
des réponses concrètes à la question que
vous devez tous posé dorénavant que
peut-on faire pour vivifier notre
communauté et la nature et pour tendre
vers l'autosuffisance territoriale fait
ça vous ferez naître des espoirs lucide
accessoirement je dormirai mieux et nous
dormirons de tous mais je crois par
avance merci
[Applaudissements]